I don't get this Sam Smith thing it just
seems like every week he deliberately
why is one person there because that's
how they identity why have I got to go
along with it because they've asked you
to he's doing what pop stars have done
for decades which is trying to shock and
the thing that makes it different from
other people is that when Justin
Timberlake or Rihanna or someone
stripped down they do so because they
look good like their bodies look good
Sam Smith is like pudgy and very ugly
you know what you're both CIS white
straight man you can carry on I'm not
assist anything first of all I am white
secondly I am a man thirdly I've been
out and gay my entire adult life I was
out as gay when you were still prancing
around talking about whether or not you
were it's a shame to the queen you know
what I tell you who's really
embarrassing them
I gotta call Douglas after this like I
just love his